god it feels like ages since i've
covered berserk for those that don't
know or haven't read the title because
you're an agent of chaos and choose
videos at random this is a series where
i review manga completely blind going
into berserk i knew virtually nothing
about this series and now i find myself
having long since past the halfway mark
and within this video crossing into
territory of an arc with a title i
refuse to believe wasn't inspired by
star wars in any way shape or form i
mean this can't be a coincidence there
have been a lot of deviations on this
tale of self-discovery self-sabotage and
seldom before seeing horror's imposed on
guts throughout his sprawling journey to
i guess dedify griffith who was his
friend sort of who he bested in
one-on-one battle who went off to do
terrible things to a princess who got
tortured for that who almost died who
became an angel of darkness and then
reborn anew all the wild gods has
but thankfully this complex story within
this arc starts to quell the flow of
questions being asked and instead starts
to answer some as we move towards what
now feels like a tangible goal with a
host of brand new character arcs that
honestly had me enjoying it far more
than the conviction arc for reasons i
will get into in this video is that a
controversial take i don't know but what
i do know is that i am totally not mark
and this is my blind review of berserks
falcon of the millennium empire arc part
1.
[Music]
one thing i can say about berserk
categorically is that it is dense as all
hell when it comes to its plot themes
and character writing and not
necessarily in that order either for
that reason i wasn't able to cover
everything i wanted to in the last
episode where i covered the conviction
arc's ending and so thankfully because
this arc is much less complex we have
some extra time to quickly give my
impressions on what happened with all
that craziness and while i really want
to get into how this arc kicks off like
seriously what happened took me so off
guard i nearly fell back into my chair i
want to talk about mr eggman
i'm going to try to be honest here i'm
not sure i fully grasped what happened
with regards to this weird guy following
everyone and lurking in the shadows
throughout a portion of that arc with
that said something about his design
mixed with his uncharacteristic lack of
involvement with the story made me feel
i don't know uneasy in ways this story
hasn't managed to achieve thus far and
i've seen some stuff in this story upon
closer inspection the conviction act
generally speaking is all about what
people desire the most and the
conviction that it takes for them to
achieve those ends ironically or
fittingly while the entire world is
begging for salvation in the conviction
arc the eggman who comes from the worst
most rotten places of society someone
who doesn't even really consider himself
a person is the one that works as a
vessel for this quote salvation granting
an answer to those desires by bringing
the hawk of light into the mortal world
griffith is back and seems to be totally
fine again in his mortal form which is
oh my god i don't even know if i can
process that right now the eggman as
someone who watched over albion and its
people first as a spectator and later as
some sort of participant transforming
mozgus and his torturers into
semi-apostles is easy to miss at first
but how this tiny thing became the
center of the story still without
anybody noticing and achieving his own
goals by literally changing the world
forever is poetic and sort of prophetic
in a sense when you think about this
arc's title the furthermore and we're
getting there the cursed child of kaska
and guts appeared many times during the
story seemingly to protect casca but in
the end runs out of gas or dies either
way he is absorbed by the eggman so they
both don't die alone which is so
fittingly berserk i don't know why i
didn't see that coming is this the end
of this character
i'm not so sure i don't think miura
would make the cursed child show up just
to help out the main character and then
vanish but only time will tell i guess
by the end of the conviction arc itself
the predictions of skull night are once
again challenged by guts and once again
while everything happens according to
what he says one thing remains different
guts and casca are reunited and it's
thanks to all the people guts knew and
all the people that decided to follow
him throughout this story interestingly
there are some similarities between
events from the past that we can notice
here too we have another eclipse
griffith is reborn into another divine
being guts and casca are saved and even
some parallels i mentioned before
between fairness and casca also exist
and if we want to get really crazy there
could be some inversions that play here
too the hawks died during the eclipse in
golden age's climax while guts's new
friends all survive in conviction and
some of them even decide to follow his
tracks perhaps this is an indication
that guts is slowly edging his way to an
outcome that's imminently desirable
rather than an outright horror show or a
compromise like this conviction climax
was but okay to round out my analysis of
the conviction arc's conclusion before i
move on to something else i think i
should share my favorite part of this
story which was guts's choosing of
protection for casca over vengeance
towards griffith having once been a man
destroying himself on this endless
violent crusade for revenge thanks the
lessons he's learned in this story chose
the less indulgent and selfish option
guts the protector of kaska and
interestingly the panel structure here
seems to be a homage to one of miora's
favorite mangas
just a fun fact that i thought i'd
include with that said griffith's
rebirth is astonishing the circumstances
surrounding the kingdom with the kushan
army in stride is pretty suspenseful the
people of midland full of fear and hope
is appropriate and guts and casca
fighting for their lives and griffith
flying over some of the most incredible
landscapes i've ever seen in manga kicks
off this next arc
falcon of the millennium empire as i
noted towards the beginning of the last
section one of the arc's strong points
is i think it's ability to take complex
emotional stakes and present them in a
format that's honestly quite easy to
follow on a surface level this will help
in my conciseness when writing this
review and so instead of going through
things one at a time in a boring fashion
considering that this arc thus far is
split up into two plot lines guts and
griffiths respectively i thought the
best way to tackle this video is by
exploring my impressions on each of
these plotlines individually that is
after what happens in the very first
scene of this arc when guts arrived with
kaska in tow to their small base of
operations and i saw that griffith was
waiting for them i think i had what
could only be described as a mild
aneurysm after having come to terms with
choosing to protect casca after giving
up what was the perfect opportunity to
take him out at the climax of the prior
arc seeing him here like this was one of
the most stunning instances i've
experienced in the story there's been a
running trend since the very beginning
of this manga with it framing a number
of instances and moments highlighting
that griffith is out of reach of guts
sometimes metaphorically and sometimes
quite literally however there have been
instances where he surprised even
griffith with his very existence flying
in the face of what should have happened
to him by now he should have died gutz's
sheer determination to struggle onward
towards his goal is the savage heartbeat
of this story however in this scene
kicking things off while griffith
appears to be the same person he knew
back then as he has been in the case of
every prayer tale he is still
unreachable
zod the immortal stands before guts as
the formidable obstacle he is with a new
conviction his sword once lost in the
boredom of thousands of battles finds a
new purpose to protect his overlord
griffith against the giant dragon slayer
of guts once more the two rivals clash
while watching this take place it felt
almost as if time was standing still
while the action is naturally as good as
one might expect from miora with some
outstanding illustrations on display it
was griffith's short conversation with
guts that retook the reigns of this
scene for me this is the first time
these two have been in communication
with each other in such a long period of
time and for griffith to effectively
espouse the same rhetoric and vibe as
when he was in the golden age arc is
both nostalgic and haunting at the same
time with the context of what's happened
since those simpler times and it's in
this short but illuminated conversation
we noticed something a little different
about guts instead of the man who had a
clear conviction for revenge or
protection he seems to be stuck in a
sort of limbo unable to fully and
completely dedicate himself to one goal
more on that in just a bit there was one
instance that i found quite surprising
during this scene and that was
griffith's sudden protection of kaska
there's the obvious contrast being made
here with guts in that griffith seems to
be single-minded in his goals and
therefore without hesitation can act in
this case protecting kaska however this
conflicts quite violently i think with
the heinous acts he's perpetrated in the
past to both guts and specifically casca
he's perfectly willing to sacrifice any
number of people if it means him
reaching his goal of ruling over a
kingdom but this stands in direct
contrast with that i'm not sure what to
make of it but perhaps it's a mind game
the very last time god saw griffith in
this state and appearance he had left
griffith outmatched and defeated on his
knees as he walked off in the snow snow
in this series carries with it a
tremendous amount of symbolism i've
noticed it can be interpreted as the
cleaning of the old slade and fresh
start and it can be emblematic of
isolation and emptiness when godz
defeated griffith back during the golden
age arc he inadvertently shook the
status quo in everyone's eyes and
griffith knew that which in addition to
his caring for guts was part of the
reason why he reacted like he did
however this scene's conclusion almost
acts as griffith's revenge for that
moment as he leaves guts alone in the
snow after a crushing battle with his
minion zod with him holding all the
cards and through kaska reminding him of
what he did to her but that's just my
take
following this scene the two main
characters guts and griffith fracture
into two separate storylines while they
naturally reconnect at a later point i
will be diving into guts's portion of
the story first as it's by far what i
have the most to talk about and by
extension what i've found the most
entertaining and interesting
right now i totally not mark the youtube
channel yourself graciously decided to
click on i decided to bring you an ad
for an energy drink you only vaguely
recognize in a video that has nothing to
do with energy drinks even tangentially
on a site that no one would ever think
to search for energy drinks ever
inexplicably they decided to sponsor me
for not one but an entire year's supply
of monthly videos with full creative
control morons and to show my
appreciation for frankly preposterous
and unjustified vote of confidence i've
decided to push their patients to the
absolute limit by making statements like
gene field is directly responsible for
global climate change funding isis
directly and tastes like baboon water is
any of this true should you buy g fuel
what is popping water why are you
looking at me for answers i am an idiot
so what are you waiting for grab
yourself a bottle of baboon water today
and piss off
guts picking up the pieces following
this climactic battle a new goal or
destination becomes apparent casca
cannot take care of herself and this
safe haven they once knew has been
destroyed because of guts's battle with
zod perhaps again this could be symbolic
that guts can't have it both ways he can
protect kaska while also fighting zod
and by proxy griffith this speaks to the
conflict in guts's mind which this arc
deals with predominantly as he travels
to pock's home the land of the elves and
this is where the character running for
guts gets extremely interesting on these
travels gotz realizes how difficult it
is fighting the demons of the night that
attack while also having to consider
casca's protection everything was easier
when he didn't need to hold back when he
could indulge in that more animalistic
side of himself that side that he knew
could struggle and survive however he
can't do that now he has to fight 10
times harder in order to stay alive and
to protect kaska and can't afford to be
a savage sword seeking blood any longer
now he instead has to learn to be a
shield and a sword the pressure of which
ends up breaking him a sentiment echoed
through quotes like sword feels heavier
than ever or casca is a shell of the
person she once was is there any trace
of the old casket inside of her or even
he wanted to rescue her and now he did
now what he reached the goal but how can
he keep his promise to her and to
himself of never abandoning her all of
these quotes speak to the frustration
the conflict and ultimately the mindset
of guts that wants to believe casca is
worth it but just like in every
difficult challenge there's always that
side that tries to rationalize away out
of that tough responsibility
particularly when the stakes are as high
as they are for guts and this is where
miura decided to explore something
really interesting within guts's
character since the beginning of the
story there's always been a more primal
or beast-like persona that guts would
embody in order to successfully survive
his day-to-day existence what i once
thought was an artistic choice depicting
guts as this beast of the darkness has
become a very tangible and real plot
element since lost children we've been
aware of the beast in black and
following a difficult series of
frustrations surrounding casca
struggling to protect her and even
questioning whether or not he should any
longer she goes
missing after having promised himself
that he would never lose her again in
the adrenaline fear and frustration guts
snaps the beast once again takes over
and in the process
hurts kaska scars kaska the person he
loves the most in a fashion eerily
reminiscent of what griffith committed
he became a monster and if we ignore the
obvious and awful imagery for a second
there's a phenomenal piece of
storytelling taking place here through
this character that calls all the way
back to the very beginning of his life
and that character being called back to
is
gambino when we were first introduced to
gambino way back at the very beginning
of the golden age arc we were presented
with this rough around the edges tough
soldier type that was good at what he
was a soldier a fighter a killer if he
wasn't good at being that then he would
have likely died long before he could
even have been any sort of father figure
good or bad to guts when he was younger
however once he lost the ability to
fight he started to more obviously and
overtly lash out in terrible ways which
ultimately led to his downfall he
couldn't be a good father a good
nurturer or a good carer perhaps in part
because all of his life he had to do the
opposite to survive to look out only for
himself this obviously isn't to excuse
anything he did in the story but it
speaks to perhaps his mindset and
psychology when in those moments this
facet of his being being perhaps so
useful in keeping him alive that it
became who he was and when he was
stripped of his ability to utilize that
strength he broke similarly guts has
lived a life as of late where he's been
forced to fight for his life against
odds he's been told are insurmountable
with death waiting around every single
corner in order to survive this miura
has shown us how animalistic and
beast-like he becomes once fighting off
hordes of monsters and demons defying
what he was told was impossible it
served him as a useful function and as
such has pushed him in a direction of
being someone that wants to be alone and
wants to be someone that relishes in
crushing the weak and taking what he can
for himself which brings us to this
moment where he makes the decision to
not indulge in those heinous acts any
longer and instead do what's difficult
he decided to care to care for and above
all else protect kaska and along the way
he quickly discovers how difficult it is
to do that how difficult it is to remain
compassionate and human in those dire
circumstances and how easy it might be
during those more difficult moments to
allow oneself to be lost to those darker
impulses in other words in real time we
are seeing what it might have been like
for someone not as strong as guts to go
through something like this in gambino
what it might have been like for a
prisoner of war who can't let the battle
go and following this guts feels
horrific and rightfully so the very same
trauma got experienced and in many ways
still is experiencing after what gambino
did to him was what he passed on to
casca what he scarred casca with the
fear of being touched or more
specifically in this instance the fear
of guts himself how can they keep going
well euro gave us an answer almost
immediately guts needs help
farnese and serpaco since their
introduction to this story halfway
through the conviction arc after lost
children the dynamic of serpico and lady
farnese has been an enjoyable one and
perhaps that's putting it a little too
lightly serpico from the outset is very
easy to respect and cheer for even when
he decided to take on the main character
guts on the side of a cliff during the
conviction arc i still found myself
cheering his innovative and
opportunistic efforts in taking down
guts to help his lady farnese however
with her on the other hand having been
introduced as a religious extremist with
strong swathes of sadism right beneath
her unassuming and innocent facade lady
farnese has been a character i never
thought i would get the chance to
actually explore in greater detail
let alone appreciate berserk is in one
way or another quite interested in
demonstrating how awful people can be
while also possessing the courage to
explore the reasons as to why that might
be the case fernies is shown to be a
hateful entitled scornful bigot that
relishes in the literal burning of
innocent people and yet through the
flashbacks we receive either through
serpico and herself we discover that her
upbringing was far from normal or secure
in some senses through the eyes of
serpico himself circo's journey and
history is as you might expect he's a
determined attentive and appreciative
individual with unwavering loyalty to
those he feels a connection with having
come from the slums and from a mother
that struggled to cling to reality it
was farnese's request to take him in
that ultimately plucked him from a life
of scrounging to a life by her side
where serpico ended up witnessing some
of the unsavory aspects of her character
and many of her struggles first hand and
this is where there might be a parallel
to point out with regards lady fairness
and kaska kaska and farni's are sort of
a package deal in this arcuase all the
while guts does what guts does best hack
and slash farnese guards kaska with her
life something she never would have done
when we first encountered her in other
words she seems to be on a path to
redemption it's made clear early in this
act that farnese carries with her in
admiration and curiosity for guts and
what he's managed to show her since
meeting him her entire worldview has not
only been challenged but successfully
shattered compare this to cask's
experience with griffith who changed her
worldview and following that held her
devotion kaska was lost in a fantasy and
idealistic cocoon-like vision of what
griffith really was farnese on the other
hand by following gods has managed to
actually better herself she's gotten
stronger both mentally and physically
and in addition to that surprica has
even remarked that she's becoming more
compassionate she's starting to feel
more human in other words guts was a
positive influence on her life while
griffith was a negative one on casca's
and fittingly farnese becomes kaska's
security blanket in this section
isidro there isn't a lot to discuss here
at least not in comparison to guts casca
farnis or even serpico but i am
thoroughly enjoying what isidro
contributes to the story in more than
one way on a surface level there's
something to appreciate with his growing
rapport alongside puk their comedy helps
to alleviate the dire or intense scenes
a little bit and by doing so helps to
enhance those more serious moments by
creating a wonderful contrast in tone a
similar technique has been used not only
in comics but also live action films for
decades for reference think about how
effective robin williams was at shifting
from humor to more dramatic tones in the
blink of an eye they often go hand in
hand i mentioned before that i
appreciated the commonalities that
existed between isidro and a more
traditional shonen protagonist also
which shine through magnificently within
this portion of the story while he is by
no means the focus the minor subplot or
character arc he's undergoing in this
arc is quite cathartic he wants to be
the best of what he's trying to do and
when he doesn't measure up to the other
talents of other warriors in the party
like guts or serpico you can visibly see
the disappointment in himself descend
across his face and while this aspect of
him is explored in more detail with guts
encouraging him to use his strengths and
to follow what feels right to him the
real struggles in his development are
made with the introduction of a brand
new character and addition to the party
the little witch shiruke
and the astral world magic has joined
the party ladies and gentlemen now that
might sound like a tongue-in-cheek
comment but in reality it's true i don't
want to spend a ton of time speculating
on the circumstances surrounding the
astral world and what the ramifications
of that might be because i'm smart
enough to understand that i can't fully
comprehend the scope of what this offers
the story in the future however i will
speak to what i think of the character
shiroke the little witch in training is
an interesting addition to the story
from a conceptual and utilitarian
standpoint with regards to the narrative
she offers a bunch to the party that
they otherwise cannot do and she acts as
a manifestation of magic in this world
in a big and bombastic way and quite
auspiciously she offers an interesting
contrast to isidro's character too
whereas sidrow acts as a naive blowhard
surprised when he can't live up to his
own expectations cheetah case seems to
be the exact opposite of that she's had
the necessary training the backing of
her mentor and teacher but lacks the
belief in herself and her abilities in
many ways to fully make use of them this
is specifically interesting as a
citroen's dynamic with her fuels his own
insecurities acting at first towards her
as one of the boys in this team he
slowly realizes that she is far more
capable than he is feuding this feeling
of inadequacy that he has and that's not
even to make mention of the magic on
display here since griffith did the
whole ooga booga and became the demon of
the night and then the hawk of light
once again in his reincarnation it's no
exaggeration to state that in the
immortal words of will smith this world
has been flip turned upside down demons
are everywhere and now magical creatures
roam the land thanks to the astral world
intersecting with the reality guts
understands interestingly she decay all
the while she has to contend with her
own uncertainty i adore what she means
for the story and how she impacts the
actions of the rest of the party that
isn't even to make mention of the
massive water bending and darkness
entity she manages to entangle herself
within which in and of itself is
inherently interesting as a power set
from a visual standpoint but also
because of the drawback to using such a
massive amount of magic at numerous
times we see her unable to disconnect
and almost lose herself in these moments
of entanglement and it's just
fascinating watching as she picks and
chooses when to make use of these
abilities she has particularly
interesting in the context of her being
this fledgling witch tasked with holding
everyone else's hand through this
experience it's wonderfully handled like
she gives the team their own enchanted
items serpico becomes a feather dusting
air bender isidro becomes a pyromaniac
and guts gets the big black armor
otherwise known as the berserker armor
i touched on this aspect of gutz's
character in the early portion of this
video and cited his more animalistic
side coming out manifesting in a very
physical and real way it was horrific
and well this berserker armor is sort of
the natural extension on that idea with
even more trade-offs beyond the clear
and obvious psychological ones on both
himself
and those he inflicts pain upon the
berserker armor as i understand it is
brilliant for all the same mechanical
reasons as the kaioken is in dragon ball
z there's a tremendous entertainment and
suspense factor attached to it while it
amplifies the wearer's strength and
resilience the damage the body is forced
to absorb is compounded by the armor's
ability to keep the wearer going this
aspect of the armor in addition to the
primal animalistic and frankly demonic
state guts is now tapping into creates
the perfect storm for this armor to work
its magic and work its magic it most
certainly does once griffith's forces
ambushed the team with one of the main
warriors in those forces grunbelled
looking to take on guts one on one and
with the berserker armor it becomes
clear that grunbelt despite wanting a
real fight must assume his real form in
order to survive this encounter with
this new power of guts and his real form
is oh it's spectacular the dude is a
giant crystal dragon the page spread
revealing his true form was absolutely
gorgeous it's certainly up there with
some of the most impactful page turns
for me in this series and i love how his
white regal and bright facade clashes
and contrasts starkly with the black
savage and dark appearance of guts and
his newly acquired armor the fight is
great but ultimately serves the
narrative function of communicating how
his new berserker armor works and long
story short it's sick and it works great
the beach guts and his party at the
beach is a beautiful chapter with miura
at his best in terms of character
writing shuriken and guts begin to
formulate the foundations of a closer
relationship ultimately focusing on the
issues that both he gotz and shi shiroke
have to contend with moving forward with
both of them carrying a tremendous
amount of weight on their shoulders
respectively both dealing with difficult
decisions they need to make shitake
needing to follow her late teachers
lessons in finding a way to believe in
what guts can do despite her head
telling her that it's impossible which
is sort of ironic because she deals
specifically in magic which in and of
itself is sort of beyond belief and then
we have guts on the other hand staring
at what he could be pursuing a quiet and
normal life for kaska but this is
berserk and a tranquil quiet moment
can't last too long cutting this warm
moment short skull line appears again to
tease us once more with guts's destiny
and in doing so addresses something
important helping us understand that in
order to deal with griffith one has to
challenge the world's rules this speaks
to shitake's issue somewhat but i wonder
if this armor gutz has recently acquired
transcends his body to something more
than human or perhaps he could be
speaking to his demonic state only time
will tell i suppose but one thing that
has struck me from this arc has been
when skull knight remarks on some
potential good news guts received about
casca the elf king they are heading
towards seems to have the ability to
restore kaska to who she was once before
this is insanely great news for guts
however this is berserk skull knight
speculates as to whether or not casca
will wish for the same thing gutz
desires and it's a frightening sentiment
and possibility for guts to have to
contend with however the more i think
about it the more i can make sense of
that statement it's been remarked upon
numerous times that this casket is
distinctly different to the casket we
all know and love from before in golden
age and so in theory making this wish
for her in a sense would be like asking
to be killed and born anew this current
casket would need to make the wish to
reset and restore the previous casket
with different memories an entirely
different person suddenly this fairy
tale-like mechanic is dealing with some
really complex philosophical questions
about identity and existence
the final thing i want to acknowledge
about guts's squad before i move on to
griffith is this little kid that casca
picks up at the beach there's something
weird about this kid something mystical
or i don't know something they sort of
looked like mokuba from yu-gi-oh and
with this thematic tie to kaska i can
only imagine how this little one would
play a role in how his story unfolds
moving forward
griffith and speaking of unfolding
stories it's finally time to properly
meet the invaders to midland and by
association griffith to this portion of
the story now seeing as i will only be
reviewing the first half of this arc
griffith's portion of the story is
actually significantly smaller than the
team of guts's so let's explore what i
can concerning his return and expansion
into midland much the same as the golden
age arc griffith is depicted as this
ethereal and angelic presence descending
onto the filthy commoners groveling in
fear since the beginning of the story
the kushan empire has never been a focus
but boy does it play a leading role as
the main obstacle to griffith and his
new crew the new band of the hawk is
unveiled piece by piece to us with each
subsequent area griffith conquers and
liberates coming from the cushion empire
and with it bringing a new addition to
his crew there's this little girl called
sonja that has this strange almost
psychic ability and similar to kaskas
she has become infatuated or obsessed in
a sense with griffith for it was his
presence she believes that granted her
that power other characters joined the
ranks early on both human and i guess
dragon alike as we saw earlier however
we don't really come to fully comprehend
the full scope of griffith's new army
until we come to know the character of
mew a newly liberated leader that soon
gets befriended by sonia and in her
efforts to introduce him to griffith
personally she walks him past
increasingly creepier and creepier
followers until he reaches a literal
demonic entities lurking in the dead of
night griffith is dealing with a whole
new level of force when it comes to his
army granting us perhaps a glimpse of
the sort of kingdom griffith expects to
rule over of all the conquests and
captures in these chapters for griffith
and the new band of the hawk by far my
favorite scene comes in the form of
griffith's advancement and attack on the
cushion emperor ganeshka this fellow is
an apostle yes however he is distinctly
different to all the others we've seen
so far as he refuses to vow himself to
any one allegiance beyond his own not
even the godhead by their very nature
apostles normally will follow the orders
of the god hand yet this character wants
to transcend them he says i'll reign
over this unclean world as a demon king
and rebel against
god he wants to become a higher power
which makes him the perfect enemy to
griffith in this part of the story
however i would be lying if i said that
this character alone is the reason this
scene is my favorite because he's not
he's not even remotely my favorite
aspect of it
this is there's a tremendous amount of
history between griffith and princess
charlotte we know what griffith wants we
know what he's done in the past to her
we know what he's become we understand
charlotte's desire to be with him again
and we can all see where this whole
scene is going what was once depicted as
a horror show when griffith last climbed
through her window is presented in this
instance like a fantastic joyous
storybook ending to a romance that
spanned generations the paneling here is
spectacular and the look on charlotte's
face says it all carried forth by a
one-horned beast across the sparkling
night sky atop her bed griffith her
dazzling prince charming has come to her
rescue where this will go
i perish the thought which finally
brings us full circle to the unexpected
reunion of the two main parties gotz's
team and griffith's band and strangely
there's no conflict upon first encounter
griffith doesn't see guts again but
instead shurike encounters sonja the
girl that can read pines
where will this go well we gotta read
ahead and see i hope you all liked this
video even half as much as i loved this
arc berserk is an incredible story that
never seems to ease up or lose itself in
the impossible scope miura has brought
to these pages i hope to see you all
there for the next video but until then
i've been toy not mark i'll see you all
next week and thank you all so much for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]